right now a family is looking for
answers after their dog died days
following with stay at a local boarding
facility madison kimbrough spoke to that
heartbroken family she's here now to
explain what happened
on a day where families come together
the intensio family is in mourning after
losing their dog connor they believe he
was severely mistreated during his stay
at pazas sitter grooming and boarding
facility and that facility is to blame
for his death
i want the place to be shut down you
know they should not be doing this to
any animal a nightmare for nancy and her
family as their beloved cocker spaniel
connor died wednesday this just days
after being cared for by pizazz sitter
boarding facility on nellis and kerry
avenue in the east valley when the
antensios picked up connor after being
gone on vacation for eight days they
knew something was wrong and when they
brought him back home his condition
worsened he was still shaking
i noticed he had blood in his urine he
had blood in his stool he
he had like a
look like to me like his jewel was a
brownish color she opens up his mouth
and i realized that
his teeth were missing realizing he
needed medical attention they made a vet
appointment for december 22nd then that
morning horror struck when they found
connor unresponsive on the couch dead
not having him bark at me and jump on me
when i come through the door when
i come home from work
you know having you know my youngest
youngest daughter
you know buy him a christmas present a
new new toy and everything
and
he's not even here scott immediately
went back to paws as to get answers and
they refused to tell him anything about
kana's stay he took to social media and
it turns out there are numerous reports
from other people about their dogs being
mistreated there too it just it
tears me apart how many people out there
that this has happened to that it's not
just us
and i just want justice for kana
now in the last couple of hours we have
received two calls into our newsroom
from people claiming that they've gone
through similar experiences with this
boarding facility we reached out to
pause for comment but no response and we
also noticed that they've taken down
their facebook page reporting live in
studio i'm addison kimbro back to you
david